هكذا تحولت العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء خلال
ثماني سنوات من سيطره الميليشيات الحوثيه
عليها
انتهاكات وازمات ومشاهد ومعرفها اليمنيون
من قبل في جداريه مارب المفتوحه صورا تمثل
شهادات على تلك الجرائم وكشفا لما يحصل في
صنعاء
الاطفال والتعليم
ونهب الاموال
انتهاكات طارت الصحافه والصحافيين المراه
اليمنيه لم تكتفي الميليشيات الحوثيه
باهانتها في طوابير البحث عن الماء والغاز
بل جنه ذاتها في تشكيلات مسلحه تابعه لها
اطلقت عليها الزينبيات
واسندت اليهن مهام امنيه واستخباراتيه
واقتحام المنازل واعتقالا النساء وتعذيبهم
شواهد لفتاه انبار زوار معرض الصور
المفتوحه هنا في مارب
على المراه سواء من تعذيب سواء من سجن
سواء من همم انتهاكات همم لحقوقها من والى
ليست فقط حقوق حقوق المراه فقط ولكن
حقوقها بشكل عام فهي حقوقها بشكل كبير جدا
الجرائم ولا تسقط وذاكرته اليمنيين ليست
بثوبه يقولوا حقوقيون لتمثل الصور دليل
ادانه لمحاكمه مرتكبها هذا المعرض يحمل
رسالتين رساله للداخل همم الشعب اليمني
الذي يقبعون تحت مناظر في مناطق سيطره
الحوثي وتذكرهم بجرائم وانتهاكات الحوثي
واحياء الذهي الذهنيه للشعب اليمني بما
يرتكبوه مواصله المقاومه الشعبيه والرفض
الشعبي لهذه الميليشيات والرساله الاخرى
هي المجتمع الدولي ومهندسيه تسويات
والمشاورات بان هناك جرائم ارتكبت بحق
الشعب اليمني ولا يمكن القفز على حقوق
الضحايا اكثر من 51 الفجر
العام الماضي
انتهاكات الميليشيه الحوثيه في العاصمه
صنعاء على هذه الجداريه تبقى شاهده على
حجم المعاناه الانسانيه في مناطق سيطره
الانقلاب محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه
مارب